the easiest way to start looking for
talent and decide if you'd like to talk
to them to somebody who you meet tell
you something new in other words if if
you just know everything and they don't
tell you anything interesting why do you
want to work with them you want to work
with people who are curious who bring
something new to the party they're
creative and that's a good screen and
that'll work pretty much everywhere when
I was first an executive I would watch
people bluster ly negotiate they would
scream at each other they'd say no and
you know you're an idiot and all of the
name-calling
and I ultimately decided that was a
terrible strategy the best negotiations
are serious direct and representative of
truth if you're not going to do it say
no but also be prepared for them to
accept your no I worked for a man named
Butler Lampson who was the smartest
computer scientist of his generation he
worked at Xerox PARC and he spoke so
fast that everyone else's speech was
rated in a fraction of the rate at which
he spoke but he was much of the
architecture of what I learned well in
my career I was always underestimated as
a business person because I did not have
a business degree I think with the
success of Google that ended